[Music]
on today's show we talk all about family
we take calls about building
relationships with in-laws take calls
about dealing with in-laws who don't
know how to hold boundaries we talk
about what family values can look like
and how you live them out stay tuned
[Music]
[Applause]
it's nine o'clock on a saturday regular
crowd shuffles in
there's an old hey what's up this is
john with the dr john deloney's show
sing us the song you're the piano man
i'm not a very good singer
especially early early in the morning
but i'm glad you're with us on this show
we talk about mental health
relationships
man we pretty much talk about everything
nothing's off bounds are off limits i'm
so glad you're with us
four six nine three thirty two ninety
one if you wanna be on our show
or you can go to johnalone.com
ask
send in your questions leave a voice
message
write it up whatever you wanna do get in
touch with us we'd love to have you on
the show we talk about just about
everything man
and
i know things feel bonkers we're heading
into the holidays you'll be getting this
the episode man we'll be in the thick
holiday season so we are in it in it in
it
so glad you're with us all right let's
go to nicole in orlando hey nicole
what's going on how are we doing
good how are you outstanding what are
you doing
i am um so i have a question
um my in-laws and i have a great
relationship we go golfing we go
shopping
why do you golf can i ask you that why
do you go i'm in orlando so i think
that's what you have to do no golf is
the worst
here's the thing the only thing worse
than golfing is cat people but and i
just realized that i was a fat person so
are you a dog person
yes i am all right that's redeeming
quality i'm back all right so you can
golf as long as you got a dog with you
okay so your golf i just lost half the
internet by the way
that's awesome so all right so you golf
with them you shop with them
right we have a great relationship i
just feel like my husband and myself
have a very surface level relationship
with them
you know they don't understand like any
hardships that we're going through or we
don't understand any hardships they're
going through
and in return we kind of live in this
like
blissful optimism
life and it's just not it's just not
real life it sounds so good for uh an
in-law relationship
[Applause]
but then in return i am
you know going through hard things with
my parents and they're so supportive and
i just know that my husband's like
longing for this real relationship with
his parents ah there we go
you know it's just kind of hard he's
seen
he's seen how well my parents and i
operate and then
but he says this is the way it's always
been with his parents they've never had
this open dialogue or communication
so he's how long have you been married
three years three years so in three
years and you all dated a couple years
before that probably
yeah okay so he's getting a ringside
seat to another way
families operate
correct and he loves what he's seeing
good for you guys man that's incredible
what a testament to you and your and
your folks that's rad
and so
do you want this relationship like do
you have this dreams of calling your
mother-in-law and just
saying you're not gonna believe what
happened at work today so and so so
good-looking but
and then in her going i know you do you
want that or are you more longing for
him
i'm
i just want it to be something that i
understand the basic parts of our
relationship like
well like two examples his his father
went in to the hospital for a few days
and we didn't even know until he came
out of the hospital that sounds like my
face
and i hope my family's listening that's
exactly how my family worked
yes and then um
you know we're going through ivf to get
pregnant and his mother just keeps
asking us if we want kids so it's like
well
we do yeah yeah
you know
so have you have you ever sat down and
let me back out
so
number one good for you
most people that i talk to either on the
show or off the show especially off the
show want to distance themselves from
their mother-in-law like just i just
want to back out of this thing
completely or their father or whatever
i have personally lived
the
what do you mean such and such uncles in
the hospital i called my uncle the other
day and he's like yeah my
heart whatever where i'm doing better
and i was like you're what i wouldn't
you know i had no idea
right so
and then i complain about it and then i
get like a text right my like somebody
in my family will text me and say just
want you to know that uncle whoever is
probably
not gonna you know it's that kind of
thing so right
some of it is
a
some of it is a hard reality that some
people in our lives love us
the best they can by not telling us
things they don't want to bring us down
and they want to don't want to burden us
and no matter
how often i've said please let me know
so i can write you a letter so i can
call so i can pray for you so i can make
jokes at your expense whatever
please let me know their first instinct
when something goes wrong is
i don't want to bother anybody and
right
it drives me crazy but it is what it is
the other stuff
here's what i think
i think um just like your
husband didn't have a picture of what
this could look like
until he got to see it in action
my guess is your in-laws are very
similar they don't know what it's like
to sit down and have a
friend relationship or a deeply
connected family relationship no one's
ever shown him that
have you ever sat down and called your
mother-in-law and said hey i'd love to
just talk to you about what we're going
through and ask your opinion have you
ever experienced this have you do you
know anybody's experience and open up on
your side too
here's the horrors of ivf here's the how
much we want kids here's how expensive
it is here's how every doctor
appointment we're just our hearts are
beating fast and we're holding we're
clinching our fist
and open up to her in that way have you
ever tried that
no because i don't know if it's my place
to just try to bring this family out of
their shell and
my husband's just like it's the way it's
always been it's the way it's going to
be
okay so perfect perfect i don't know so
i wouldn't look at it as quote unquote
your responsibility
your responsibility is not to change
other people your responsibility is to
be true to nicole
and being true to nicole is you want
people in your life that are going to
walk alongside you and that you are
going to walk alongside
and the way we do that is not by i don't
know if they want if that
i'm going to just be true to myself
and i'm gonna open up and go first and
even if it means hey i know i'm your
daughter-in-law and this is weird but i
need someone to talk to about this and
i'm gonna model what this looks like and
if they abuse it
if you get a call in two weeks and they
have abused your boundaries you tell
them i don't wanna i can't stand it
people are like oh do you want kids you
want kids those questions are so hurtful
and the next week they call and say hey
do you want kids you have learned
i that's not a safe relationship for me
but you're you you are holding back
parts of you because i don't know if
it's my place
and what that leads to is secrets and
secrets lead to resentment and
resentment leads to well screw you screw
you i'm doing my own christmas all right
that's no way to live and i
wholeheartedly reject with all of my
heart the quote it's always been that
way
okay i wholeheartedly reject it now i
may go all in and realize they're not
gonna
they have no interest or no skills in
changing that's fine
but i reject that's the way that's
always been
yeah that's how family trauma stays
family trauma that's how people grow up
and what will happen is your husband
will recreate this with y'alls kids
that's what i'm worried about yes so you
go first that's what the word
vulnerability means it means i could get
hurt in this deal but i'm going to go
anyway all of this is a risk but i want
to model what this looks like and it is
not your responsibility to change them
it's just your responsibility to be
fully nicole everywhere
that makes sense
yeah and god almighty here's the thing
nicole i want you to leave your email
with kelly and i'm gonna send you a
hundred dollars every time i say the
words
does that make sense now i'm not
actually going to pay you but i'm just
going to say it out loud in my head i'm
going to keep it running total i'll
probably never send you any money but
i've got to stop saying does that make
sense because that's ridiculous but does
that make sense
yes okay good there's 100 100 bucks so
what what's the takeaway today what are
you gonna do
i'm just gonna
start
living my
life
with the relationship i want them to
have with me which is just starting to
talk about this stuff and not being
scared to talk about it yes and
challenge your husband what's your
husband's name give me a fake name let's
call him billy
okay is that his name hope it's not his
name that'd have been such a great guess
not okay
so you're like i would never have
married a billy um all right so billy
i want him to start practicing the
relationship he would love to have with
him
right
my son recently came and said hey dad
i need to talk to you about something
and dude i'm smiling right now thinking
about it it brought me so much joy that
he trusted me enough to have that
conversation i always am i'm not scared
to have any conversation ever with
anybody but even i've been like i don't
know how to lean into this one but
it was such a gift and it opened up a
whole new thing
your husband may have the keys to unlock
your parents relationship and there's
just been this weird dance for so long
he can free everybody it'd be incredible
so tell him you all sit down and say hey
what would we want to talk about with
our in-laws
what would we want to talk about what do
you want to know from your dad do you
have some questions about hey what was
it like when you and mom were trying to
have kids and were you nervous were you
scared give dad an opportunity to open
up to some of those things hey dad we
just talk about sports and weather
i was wondering what it's like to be
married to somebody who's trying to get
pregnant like walk me through that all
right dad can i ask your advice on this
money question or this
whatever quit
have your husband lean in and it could
be weird and awkward and his dad could
pick i don't want to talk about that son
or i'm going to give you one word but at
least he's going for it and we're not
just living in this i don't know i don't
know i don't want to stop my job it's
not i'm going first
so cool what a great question nicole hey
and blessings to you and your ivf
journey i know that is a nightmare for
folks and so we are rooting for you here
with the john colony gang all right
everybody we'll be right back on the dr
john dolone's show
[Applause]
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john deloney show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six month waiting list or
i can't afford it or they only take
insurance or i can't get off work and
time to go see somebody and it's way
across town what do i do because i want
help with my anxiety my depression my
relationships are hanging on by a thread
i want to be a better mom i gotta
process this trauma that happened to me
when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with better help because
better help is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapist if you
reach out to them you will be talking to
somebody within 48 hours dr john dolone
show listeners get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com
all right hey i got this question i
guess this is turning into like a family
theme show here i got an email question
from chris hello chris hello john good
to talk to you brother or sister i don't
know
chris says i hear you talk about family
values
yeah that's kind of a cornerstone of the
show and now everyone in the household
has a role to fill
i was wondering if you could explain
that in more detail
i guess yes okay so
i will get it that chris and if i miss
your question
holly batgirl at me on the internet so
we can try to figure it out all right so
here's what i mean by family values
everyone's got a role to fill when i say
family values the question i'm asking is
who are we
what are we about
and what happens a lot is
parents a never asked that question of
themselves
they never asked that question of the
their relationship like as a married
couple who are we what are we what are
we trying to do on earth
and then they never communicate that to
their kids
and so kids enter the world into
somebody else's world
with only a few tools screaming
and trying to get attention trying to be
seen
and trying to
backfill trying to leap over and create
connection with mom and dad because mom
and dad are busy they're both working
and they're both scanning pinterest or
they're both playing video games or
whatever they're doing they're running
and running and running and running
and
kids are untethered and you hear me say
that a lot here's what that means kids
are unconnected to the purpose what are
we doing here in this house are we just
like eating and yelling and
doing chores and
then go to school and then go to bed and
repeat like what are we doing
i think so much existential angst in
teenagers and in
middle school kids and in adults
is we grow up in houses and we don't
even know why we're what we're doing we
don't know why we're there what are we
what are we doing and then
like you go to some random
school and they try to pump into you
what your purpose of life your purpose
of life is get straight a's and go to
college
and then you go to college like your
purpose of life is to find your passion
follow your dreams do whatever whatever
or you go to some like coach and he's
like the purpose of your life is to win
games and to stretch yourself and to
dominate and crush and kill it all
whatever and then you go to work and
they're like your purpose is to make
money and make me money and
rock onto the break of don't whatever
or you go to some church some youth
group thing and they're like your
purpose is to just love or whatever or
fight culture or whatever the thing is
and kids are getting these messages all
over the place and they're untethered
and adults are getting these messages
all over the place instagram is like
your purpose is to live your best you
yolo
bro whatever i don't know all the olos
olo yola ho i don't know yahoo that's
chocolate milk i think you're supposed
to like just do a thing
we're all getting these messages and so
in my house we sat down and said what
are we doing like why are we doing this
me and my wife sat down and said who are
we what are we trying to accomplish on
this planet on our short little time
with our one precious life we got we're
on a rock flying through space what are
we trying to do here
and then we bring the kids in
and say
here's who we are here's what it means
to be a deloney
and here's what it means to be a part of
the delony family and i look at my
daughter who's five and i say
you are a cornerstone of this family
this machine this this organism this
thing that we are doesn't operate
without you and i look at my son and say
you not only have a role to play you are
a cornerstone of this thing
this this family doesn't work right
without you
and here's who we are and so i've talked
about a little bit and i meant to bring
it i forgot i'm an idiot um
we went to like michael's or one of the
craft stores crafts etc one of those
craft stores and we got a canvas
and we sat down together and we're about
to do it again over the holiday season
my wife and i actually had this
conversation two nights ago
and we just wrote down who are we
what are the delony family values
and they were things like we are
hospitable
we say yes
we have adventures
we treat each other and strangers with
dignity and respect
we don't step over messes like these are
things that we are
and then
once a kid feels tethered in this is
what i'm doing on this planet
this is what i'm anchored into both when
it comes to values
and as it comes to like my daily
operations how i live these values out
then
here's the next thing
most of our responses as parents not of
ours and i'm saying this universal
become
well i love you and you screwed up so i
got to hit you now or i love you but you
screwed up so not coming fishing with me
or you don't get to do this thing we
were going to do
and it makes love and the relationship a
weapon
and it makes the kid feel like oh i've
got to behave
so that i don't get beat up or i've got
to behave so that that person will still
love me or that person will still remain
connected to me
and i think that's madness
instead your child has a role in your
home that everybody agrees on
intentionality and there are extreme
consequences that now the kid is
choosing
not the adult
and i want my three-year-old i want my
four-year-old i want my seven-year-old i
want my 18 year old to understand you
chose to
not go fishing and as your dad
i am choosing to be heartbroken because
man i really wanted to spend time with
you
i can't i breaks my heart that you chose
to opt out of this thing by not filling
in the blank
you chose to not have dinner with us
tonight because you're yelling and being
rude and disrespectful
so i can say man
we need you at this table i want you at
this table this table is not whole and
complete without you
and you opt it out because you
are disrespectful and that violates one
of our family core values
and so i'm not sending you away get away
from my table get out of here
ah you chose to leave
and i tell my kids that i choose to be
sad when they leave because i miss them
i want them around i don't breathe as
well when they're not in in our presence
and over time they learn that they
choose their responses they choose their
behaviors they choose their actions they
choose all of their choices
so when i have one of my kids is
throwing a temper tantrum or screaming
or hollering i'll ask them why are you
choosing this behavior right now
what is this what is this choice trying
to get you
because you know that in our house we
don't yell at one another we know in our
house that we choose
to that we
choose dignity
we know in our house that we don't just
leave the dogs unfed because we make
sure that everyone from folks on the
street corner to folks in our
neighborhood to folks to dogs in our
house make sure people don't go hungry
that's one of our core values
so why are you choosing this one help me
through that and then my hope is 20
years from now they're going to be
driving down the road and someone's
going to cut them off
and they're not gonna
instantly
flip them off they're not gonna
instantly try to ride their bumper in in
so stupid and
try to cause themselves a wreck
they're gonna choose
i'm gonna
i'm gonna give them a shout out and i
hope they're okay
i'm gonna choose to slow down a little
bit because that person's clearly in a
hurry
and um i'm gonna choose just to keep
everybody safe in my area
they can or when the boss says hey i
need you to do something um
that is a little bit unethical they can
choose their choices and they'll have
chosen to not owe anybody any money and
they'll chosen to have some cash in the
bank so they can choose to say i'm not
going to be a part of this unethical
behavior i'm out you'll have a great
week you'll have a great life i i'm
resigning they can make some of those
hard choices and not be like i'm a
victim to this and i can't believe it
they can just make some choices and over
time they're gonna have less stress
they're gonna have more peace
and ultimately people are gonna wanna be
in their presence because they bring
calm to chaos they bring kindness to
dysfunction
they don't walk around angry and
frustrated and
all the time all the way back because we
told them you get to choose your
behaviors you get to choose your
thoughts you get to choose your
responses you get to choose your actions
and you get to choose
peace so that's when it comes down to
family values that's what i mean by
everyone has a role to fill
i never want my kids to go through life
feeling untethered i don't want to go
through life feeling untethered i want
my wife to go through a life feeling
untethered that we all make that
decision intentionally together around
the table great question chris hope that
helps if it didn't holler back at me and
we will um i'll dig in a little bit
deeper all right thank you so much we'll
be right back on the dr john maloney
show
one of the most common questions folks
ask me is what they should do when
anxiety or panic strikes like a
lightning bolt i've been helping folks
101 for years but i wanted to create
something that everyone could use
anywhere at any time so i created a free
guided meditation it's not really a
meditation but really me just walking
with you through your anxiety alarms
from start to finish i'll guide you
through a breathing exercise and show
you how to lean in listen and head
towards healing it is free and it's for
everyone you can download this guided
meditation today for free at
johndaloni.com
all right we are back on our
family theme show
i kind of like that let's go to dan in
denver dan you have to have a family
question or you can't be on the show
today
i do have a family question
i think hey well done dan way to go man
so what's up
yeah uh so my my mother and
father-in-law they've been going back
and forth by getting a divorce for the
past couple years that sounds healthy
and early
how long have you been married
uh we've been married just about four
years now oh boy
i'm not laughing at you man i'm i'm just
like oh man oh i know you you married
into a mess huh
i did
indeed still love them but yeah
but we we still love them it's like when
my dog craps on the floor it's like
oh we still love them all right so you
married into a mess they've been trying
to think about getting divorced for last
four years so what's up
yeah so then early last year uh things
got really bad between them my
mother-in-law actually attempted suicide
oh my gosh and
so then later in the same year
father-in-law told the whole family that
he was a sex addict and he was going to
go get treatment to help him out as far
as we know that doesn't include him
sleeping with anybody
but then earlier this year
he was told that he has early onset
dementia or is in the early stages of
dementia
and so things between the two of them
started seemed like they were getting
better but they blew up about a week ago
because it turns out
he hadn't been changing any behaviors
that he said he had been
um so now they're a lot closer to
divorce and so we're just trying to
figure out how to set up some healthy
boundaries with her family and with our
family we have one young daughter we
have another daughter due here in a
couple days and so just trying to figure
out
man
good boundaries to put in place with
this whole mess
dude homie you are in it right now man
yep
so can we just pause and talk about that
are you doing okay because this is i'm
smiling not
whenever things hit the fan uh
and i enter into a crisis situation i'll
just i'm telling you i smile it's it's
just like a way my i don't know why my
body reacts that way it's more of like
oh man now we're in it dude brother
you're in it
yep have you stopped just to take
inventory of all that's going on
in your particular life uh yeah okay i
have my wife and i we've yeah we we do
really well together talking through
these things and handling these issues
and obviously i think it's harder on her
being her parents but
it is because
it's hard because that's her parents and
she's watching him go through this and
there's some shame and embarrassment and
frustration and she's been living with
this her whole life
but also
you have a young child
you have a
very very pregnant wife you got another
child on the way
you've got covid you've got
job stuff
and you've got a hurting wife
because her family's a mess and often i
find husbands in the epicenter of those
things
and they start coming unraveled trying
to keep everything held together
yeah it feels that way yeah it feels
chaotic make sure please dan
make sure
you got a couple of buddies you can just
go hang out with okay then you can get
away and just go
man this is hard or this sucks or
let's do something let's root for the
astros or something let's do something
right
um do you have that in your life
i do okay yeah i got you
good friends good family good good good
please double down on that all right
so
you may not know the answer to this a
hallmark of sex addiction is somebody
who has lots and lots of sex
compulsively what is
what why does your father-in-law think
he's a sex addict that doesn't have sex
yeah that's so that's part of the
confusion with us the way he's described
it his sex addiction is it's just with
online issues okay a lot of pornography
and a lot of
chat rooms and stuff he's not very clear
about it
yeah it's so i don't know that's the
term he used he wasn't diagnosed that he
gave himself a diagnosis
yeah if that's his like escape from it
or an excuse to say well i'm an addict
and
okay all right that's just what that's
the term he chose to use for us okay
um and then walk me back to
your mother-in-law trying to take her
life what happened there
yeah so that was before he had like come
out and told us that he was a sex addict
but things were getting really bad
between them they were living in the
same house but on separate floors so he
was in the basement and
there was just a big argument one night
uh and she had taken a bunch of pills
and
had texted us that she's sorry she won't
be around to see us oh gosh she like
told us everything that her dad had been
doing and shared all his online profiles
and stuff and
then just said she loved us and so we
called the police and we were four hours
away from her so we
got in the car right away and drove
there and thankfully she was okay and
she seems to be doing a lot better good
i'm glad you all oh man good for you i'm
glad y'all called 9-1-1 and got involved
that way
um
this feels like and again this is not in
reference to the suicide attempt okay
but this feels like a
super volatile
highly manipulative
it feels like a mess actually
um
that really
here's my concern brother i'm afraid
this is gonna really negatively impact
your new marriage
if it hasn't already is it all ready
um honestly i don't think it has my wife
and i we i mean we spend 34 minutes a
night reconnecting and talking and
processing how we're doing and
so yeah we're together the two of us
were actually doing really well with all
of us awesome and she's a lot she's able
to get some distance between the chaos
and
madness that is her family and
understanding that y'all two have a
different relationship moving forward
yep okay all right
so here's i mean the easiest most
straightforward way to do boundaries in
your home
especially with two kids and especially
with the situation you find yourself in
is not to create boundaries from people
but to create boundaries for yourself
and so
if you just create boundaries for
they're not allowed to come over anymore
whoever they happens to be
that ends up being really difficult for
somebody when that's their mom or that's
my best friend so i hear you know like
hey that your best friend isn't allowed
in this house anymore because they're
whatever
well that feels like a personal attack
because that's my friend and now you're
saying something about me and let's
now we got other layers to this thing or
your dad's not welcome in this house
anymore he's gross he creeps me out he
always is disgusting he didn't push
stuff back i don't want him in my house
i oh that's cool i get that but that's
my dad you know what i mean so it gets
personal
the
right way to do boundaries is
what kind of ethos do we want in this
house who do we want in our home what
kind of energy do we want here who do we
want to be around
and we don't want people who are going
to be dishonest in this house we don't
want people who are going to lie about
us or to us or we don't want chaos in
this house we want people who are fun we
want and so it's a much more it's a it's
an exciting fun
um exercise to create the world that you
want to have and then people opt in or
out of that thing does that make sense
yeah i said it now i owe the previous
caller another hundred dollars man i
always say does that make sense i'm
trying to stop it's like a drug
um
so i would create boundaries about what
you do on in your home and my guess is
your in-laws are not going to fit in
that in those categories i don't want
people around my kids who are going to
be dishonest who are going to who
self-proclaim they have
sex addictions and they don't get help
for them and i don't want you or my
daughters
um i don't want people in my home that
are gonna make my wife cry
or that are gonna make me uncomfortable
in my own house whatever that looks like
and then you backfill who are the people
in my life that we're gonna we're going
to have to have hard conversations with
um
are they going to ha have it get a
divorce
uh
it's hard to say okay i really don't
know he's gone he's gone to a divorce
attorney multiple times and
he says he has papers ready to go he's
just not using them yet okay
so that's a that is a cornerstone
nonsense triangulation
threat bullcrap and that was my biggest
i just tried to do a bunch of things so
i wouldn't say bad words
so
i need you to tell him next time he does
that i don't care
i don't care
i don't care if you stay married i don't
care if you get divorced i don't want to
hear about that
or
that's a callous way to say that a more
respectful dignified way is
hey i really am uncomfortable hearing
about whether you're going to divorce my
mother-in-law or not i'll let y'all
please keep that private between y'all
too
and same with your wife if she'll have
that conversation hey dad i i don't want
to hear about you threatening to divorce
my mom that's a private marriage matter
between you all too please keep that um
in your personal thing
in your in your personal world
and i'm gonna begin to draw bound i'm
not going to get sucked into other
people's dramas not your job and not
your wife's job and i'm getting all
fired up not at you at that kind of
manipulative nonsense it's not your job
to keep their marriage together
and it's not your job to
be a punching bag for that kind of
nonsense
there he's trying to
hit his wife by hitting you
you know what i mean
yeah he's trying to get a rise out of
her by getting a rise out of you
nonsense nonsense yeah dude i cut that
crap off man
your marriage is too special to get
dragged down by that nonsense ugh i
can't stand that
he's torturing that poor woman and his
mother-in-law and
yeah i'm not getting involved in that
stuff so sit down with your wife decide
we have two kids we have we have our own
household what kind of world do we want
and then right
the ethical right way the the
integris way to do it is to sit down
with your father-in-law sit down your
mother-in-law and say here's the kind of
here's the kind of people we're gonna um
allow into our lives and here's the kind
of people we're not
every time you come to my house you talk
about this and this and this and this
i'm gonna ask you to not bring up your
marriage dysfunction in my home anymore
you need to find your own counselor your
own therapist your own friends that's
not our job
and that will be a hard conversation
if they were able to have that
conversation maturely with you or your
wife then that'd be one thing they are
immature they can't do it
and your mother your mother-in-law needs
to get some mental health support in a
major way but you can't make her do that
and
if she tells you i'm going to take my
life again of course it's your
responsibility to call on that but it's
her responsibility to take care of
herself does that make sense ah i said
it again yeah so i said it again
it works i know what you mean so what is
the what's your takeaway here man
uh yeah so we we had been talking about
some boundaries and how to set them up
and the biggest thing was trying to
figure out how we convey that to them
and i think we were going more with the
restrictive you know you're just not
allowed here
but i like what you said about you know
what kind of home do we want to have and
then
going at it from that different
perspective and having those hard
conversations because my wife's big
concern is you know maintaining those
relationships especially with you know
going to be having two daughters and she
wants them to have a relationship with
her dad and with her mom that's right so
trying to figure out how to do that
here's where this is really important
okay really important and it goes back
to the conversation i'm just having i
just uh read this email from from uh
from a caller
no matter how bad our parents treat us
we all have a fantasy that when we have
our kids here's what life with grandkids
is going to look like
and so the impetus is almost always felt
by the new young parents
to concede to
we've gotta go visit them
they
are mad that they don't get to see their
grandkids enough so we've gotta go do
this we've gotta buy these things
their grandkids are gonna wear these
kind of clothes so we gotta spend their
grandkids need to ride around in this
kind of car so we got to buy a car that
we can't even afford on payments because
we can't
it's almost always the young family that
feels the need to reach across that
aisle and that's nonsense
so
your dad
is choosing to be dysfunctional
he is making decisions to not get well
to not go to counseling to not deal with
his challenges
he is choosing to threaten
the status of his marriage with his kids
and so it's him that is choosing to not
see his granddaughters not the other way
around
and never lose sight of that okay
because you will feel so guilty
and that guilt will turn into resentment
especially with somebody who's as
immature as your father-in-law
and it's not y'all's responsibility to
deal with his or your mother-in-law's
dysfunction
it's your responsibility to protect your
children
and to create a loving rambunctious
fun
laughter joy-filled home as much as you
can control
and you can control whether a
an addict who is choosing to lie to his
family
is in
contact with your daughters
and he can choose to either be in
contact or not be in contact
does that make sense
for the third freaking time
yeah um
really watch out for the fantasy of
our time together as
a small new family
and that will be something if you have
to kill that fantasy that your
father-in-law just chooses to
not be a part of your family that your
mother-in-law chooses to not be a part
of this new young beautiful family
you all have to mourn that and grieve it
it stinks man it's not supposed to be
that way they're all supposed to hang
out together
they're supposed to
man come and bring joy and too much
candy and you're supposed to be like
they don't need that much candy and
they're supposed to be like candy
they're supposed to sneak away and get
done they're supposed to do those things
your grandparents
and if they opt out of y'all's
boundaries
that's heartbreaking
and you can choose sadness because it's
sad
but don't choose to compromise your
family's values don't choose to
compromise the integrity of your young
family who and what you want your family
to be who you want around your daughters
to try to
try to duct tape together a myth
a fantasy a picture you have about what
family's supposed to look like
because y'all are not dealing with
mature grown-ups you're dealing people
who are hurting you're dealing with
people who are choosing to not lean into
wellness they're choosing to lean into
their dysfunction it's heartbreaking man
i hate that for you guys stand strong
create the world you want to and then
have those hard conversations and by the
way dan it may be that you say
you're not welcome here but it's going
to be an outflow of what we want this to
be not i'm just going to prohibit you
from being here
and i hope you get that difference man
your kids are lucky to have two parents
like you and your wife that are looking
out for
the the culture and the energy in that
home good for you good for you good for
you all right as we wrap up today's show
i mean i i mean this just happened guy
this just fell upon itself it's a family
family show
off the search for everything album
john mayer i think this is the best song
he ever wrote
and i may have even used this earlier in
the show but now we've got a million
shows i don't even remember
the song is called in the blood it's
about family and it goes like this
how much of my mother has my mother left
in me and how much of my love will be
insane to some degree
and what about this feeling that i'm
never good enough will it wash out in
the water or is it always in the blood
and how much of my father am i destined
to become while i dim the lights inside
me just to justify someone will i let
this woman kill me or do away with
jealous love will it wash out in the
water or is it always in the blood
i can feel the love i want i can feel
the love i need but it's never gonna
come the way i am
could i change it if i wanted could i
rise above the flood will it wash out in
the water
or is it always in the blood
you can change anything and you can
change everything and that's what we're
doing right here on the dr john dolani
show
[Music]